hey smeg are you all ready
yeah can you see my slides yeah we see
your slides okay can you see them moving
too and and uh epfl are you guys set do
you have
everything's working for you
let's hope that epfl is going to
complain if something is wrong uh okay
we're delayed to have sumega garg who
was a postdoc at harvard to um continue
a theme which we also heard about from
greg valiant a few days ago on
memory sample trade-offs and learning so
sumega go ahead
okay yeah thanks sam for introduction um
today i'll be talking about an
based approach to proving memory sample
tradeoffs
this talk is based on joint work with
prabhesh ran and avishai
um
and uh
i am excited to be presenting in this
workshop
and i want to at least get one of you
excited to
work in the field so please ask me
questions
okay so in this talk uh the
computational resource that we would
care about is memory
and we would ask the question that if
learning is infeasible under memory
constraints
we will the type of problems that we
will study is is such that
statistically with the small number of
samples we can solve the learning
problem but under low memory constraints
we would not be able to solve such solve
the problem even with exponential number
of samples
so with increasing scale of learning
problems uh and limited memory on
devices it is not only philosophically
important but also becoming practically
important to study the feasibility of
learning under memory constraints
and secondly many learning algorithms
try to learn a concept or hypothesis
class by modeling it as a neural network
such an algorithm keeps in memory some
neural network and updates the weights
when new samples arrive and memory used
by such
by such an algorithm is the size of the
network which is which corresponds to a
low memory algorithm if the network size
is small
and this is just to
uh
just to
motivate the fact that we are we are we
are trying to use low memory algorithms
in
in practice
and it is important to study but what
kind of hypothesis classes these low
memory algorithms can learn
okay so a brief description of the
learner problem that uh a brief
description of the learning model that
we will uh
look at into in this talk is is of the
form uh is of the following form a
learner tries to learn a function f
uh where you have the promise that this
function f belongs to this hypothesis
class capital h
and it tries to learn this from a
sequence of samples
of the form a comma f of a that is you
get
you get a sample from the set capital a
and then the evaluation of f at this
sample and you keep on getting these
sequence of uh
evaluations uh one by one and you want
to figure out what the hidden function f
is
some of you might uh know the setting as
the setting of online learning and uh
and in this in this talk we will we will
also have we will also have a
distribution uh over the capital set a
from which these sample points are being
generated
shamir in 2014 and steinite violet
vegard in 2015 asked this question that
can one prove unconditionally stronger
lower bounds on the number of samples
needed for learning under memory
constraints in the streaming model that
is when samples are viewed one by one
and in this talk we will
do a brief survey of uh the results that
uh are
that results that were proven in this
area uh after this question was asked
so in the first section i will give you
the first example of a memory sample
trade-off that was proven in 2016 uh for
a problem called parity learning
then i will uh
and then i will
just summarize the results that were
proven after
uh after the
first result
then i will talk about a joint work with
rana and avishai which where we gave an
extractor based approach to proving uh
memory sample trade-offs for a large
class of learning problems
then we will see a bit of the proof
techniques that are used improving these
lower bounds and finally to do justice
to this workshop i want to
i want to give you the implications of
these
results for approving hardness of
refutation of csps
under low memory
and this is joint work with probation
run
okay
so let's look at the parity learning
problem
under the parity learning problem
uh an unknown function f is represented
by an n-bit string
and it is chosen uniformly at random
from the set of n bit strings
and a learner tries to learn f from a
sequence of samples of the form a comma
b
where a is another rand uniformly
randomly chosen n bit string and b is
the inner product of a with the unknown
function f in field two that is b is
some i a i times f i mod two
so in other words what is hidden from
the learner
are end variables and learner is getting
random binary linear equations in those
variables one by one and it needs to
solve for the
hidden
for the hidden
end
variables and the claim of uh and the
claim and the theorem is that this
problem is hard to learn
with uh low memory uh where we will we
will quantify the memory requirement uh
after a few slides
so uh i want to do an exercise to uh
intuitively understand why
this problem is hard to learn uh in low
memory i will give you
a sequence of equations in five
variables and please try to
solve for them
with your brain's memory but do not jot
down the equations on your notebook
catch a level
okay any guesses
one zero
i'm not sure she hears you unless we use
the mic ryan says that that there's some
ones and some zeros yeah
that's true
okay
so i predict you wouldn't have been able
to solve it unless you have a very good
memory
[Laughter]
so the answer is 0 1 1 0 1. so i
intentionally gave you many more than 5
equations it would have been easy to
figure out what what is the solution by
just writing down five equations and
doing gaussian elimination to figure out
the hidden uh set
hidden variables so this corresponds to
a parity learner that uses order and sam
order n samples and order n square
memory
so you just store the first order n
samples and with high probability these
would be linearly independent and you
can use gaussian elimination to solve
for the to solve the linear equations
and
maybe
another thing you might have tried is
i
i am going to just guess what the
function f is and try to see if that
fits the equations
and then this this
and
um
a solid learner would be it tries out
all possibilities of f one by one and
tries for the next order n samples if
this f fits uh fits the criteria so this
requires only order in memory to store
the current guess for f but it requires
exponential number of samples to learn
and
it is natural to ask can you get
something in the middle that maybe you
store some samples do some computations
and then you do not need to you reduce
some possibilities of f and you do not
need to go through exponential number of
samples but
ah
but you also not order n square memory
so but but this is not the case in our
breakthrough result in 2016 grant proved
that any algorithm for parity learning
of size and requires either memory of n
square by 25 bits or exponential number
of samples to learn
and this gave this this
tradeoff between
the memory required
by the learner and the samples required
by the learner gives this
field the name of memory sample tradeoff
so the main motivation to study these
memory sample load bounce comes from
obviously comes from learning theory
and then the second fascinating
application of these lower bounds is in
the area of bounded storage cryptography
where we we try to construct
cryptographic protocols that are secure
against
bounded memory adversaries
and there has been a good line of work
trying to construct these
cryptographic protocols using
memory sample
lower bounds
so to uh to give a teaser
uh the
the lower bound of uh run in 2016 for
parity learn it gives us a cryptographic
screen to
to exchange messages between two players
where the secret key shared by them is
just n bits long
uh
the an encryption and decryption of each
message each message bit takes n units
of time
but these players can exchange
exponential number of messages amongst
them and there and those messages would
be unconditionally secure as long as the
attacker's memory size is less than n
square by 25 bits
and then the last motivation obviously
comes from complexity theory where time
space lower bounds have been studied in
many models and the streaming model that
we study uh helps us
prove very strong lower bounds
unconditional load bonds
okay
any questions till now
okay good
so
uh
so subsequently uh the uh a paper in
2017 uh generalized these memory sample
tradeoffs to learning sparse parities
where the hidden function
has only
a few ones
and then there has been a lot of work to
generalize these memory sample tradeoffs
to even larger class of learning
problems
today i will uh focus on a joint work
with rana navishai where we gave an
extractor based approach to proving
such memory sample tradeoffs for a large
class of learning problems
so this result implied all the previous
results that is we even generalized the
technique and it gave some new load
bonds
and uh
i want to mention that this proof
technique closely follows the proof
technique of
a sequel
of a sequel to the first paper of run in
2017
and i will not go into the details of uh
this independent work but the uh in 2018
beam always and
young independently proved some related
lower bounds
okay you might remember uh this
generalization from greg stock on monday
uh so in a beautiful work uh watson
aaron and greg uh proved generalized
this memory sample tradeoffs to a
problem in continuous optimization where
they proved that any algorithm a
performing linear regression over a
stream of b dimensional examples either
use quadratic memory or have a slower
rate of convergence then that can which
can be achieved without the memory
constraint
so this provably tells us that first
order methods that use low memory
uh
have slower rate of
convergence
okay and then there has been a lot of
related work uh in the area for example
generalization generalizing uh these
trade-offs to learning under multiple
passes over the stream
proving memory sample tradeoffs for
distinguishing or testing problems or
even characterizing memory bounded
learning or proving such tradeoffs for
quantum memory bounded algorithms
so this is all i would i want to say
about the related work
uh if you want to know more or want some
references please contact
me okay
so now let's go into more uh the
technical details of uh
of this paper where uh where we study an
extractor brace approach to lower bounds
so we we formulate uh the learning
problem as a matrix as done by previous
papers
uh let capital a and capital f b two
finite sets and matrix m
uh
b was plus minus one matrix where the
rows are indexed by elements in the set
capital a and columns are indexed by the
elements in the set capital f
think of the cap
the set capital f as the concept class
and the cap set capital a as the
possible samples
so this is the matrix and then
the learning problem that we defined
corresponding they've defined with
respect to this matrix m is as follows
so a function f is chosen from the set
uh
capital f
that is
a uniformly random column is chosen
to be the unknown function f
and then a learner tries to learn f from
a steam stream of samples of the form a
comma b
where in each sample
in each sample a random row is chosen
and then what you are given is that the
matrix entry at this row and the unknown
function f
so you keep on getting uh
getting uh row indexes and
and the
and the entry at uh entry at that index
for that unknown function f
and then you want to uh from the from
the this kind of information you want to
figure out which column was is used to
generate these uh sequence of samples
this is the learning course problem
corresponding to a matrix and we want to
study what properties of this matrix
makes it an easy or a hard problem
to learn with low memory algorithms
so this is this is the property that we
study in in this paper
let us see matrix m has the following
property that any sub matrix of m
which has at least 2 to the minus k
fraction of rows and 2 to the minus l
fraction of columns
it has bias of at most 2 to the minus r
that is
if you average out the entries in this
sub matrix which are plus minus 1 then
that average
then the absolute value of that average
is at most 2 to the minus r
m so
intuitively this is saying that
most uh
most sub large sub matrices are unbiased
and if matrix m has this property then
we can prove that any learning algorithm
for this learning uh for the learning
problem corresponding to this matrix
requires either uh kl memory or
exponential in r number of samples
so this uh we we say that this is an
extractor based
based property because
because
this condition basically corresponds to
the fact that this matrix m is a two
source extractor
uh but that is not important for the
talk it's uh just this this
fact is needed
okay
any questions
uh so this is the load one that we
proved
and
the applications of this lower bound is
that we can prove that low degree
polynomials are hard to learn under
lower low memory so which which
corresponds to the following problem
let's say a learner tries to learn an
invariant multilinear polynomial p which
has degree at most t
ah from random evaluations of p over f
to the n that is
a polynomial of degree d is uh hidden
and at every step you are getting a
sample point and the evaluation of p at
that sample point
and then you want to learn what the
hidden uh uh polynomial p is
so
statistically you can just uh so you can
just store the first end to the d um
uh uh points and evaluations of the
polynomial p on those points and you can
solve for the hidden polynomial p
and we prove and this this corresponds
to a n to the d plus one memory
algorithm and uh
we can we are able to prove that this is
tight that is you either require
a memory of n to the d plus one or
exponential number of samples
and then uh we are also able to prove
that learning from sparse equations is
hard that is
a learner tries to learn f which is b
think of f as n variables
uh
from a random sparse linear equations of
sparse tl
uh
that is uh n variables are hidden and at
every step you get an equation which
depends only on l variables
uh and you want to learn the hidden this
hidden
uh satisfying assignment or the hidden x
and for this we can show that it either
you you either require nl memory or
exponential l number of samples
and this is a result that we will use
improving sample lower bounds for
refuting csps in the streaming model
under memory constraints
which i will talk about after the proof
overview
but any questions till now
so
to prove our lower bound uh we model the
learning pro learning algorithm as a
branching program as done by previous
papers
um
a learning algorithm that uses uh s bits
of memory and
m samples can be
can be modeled as a branching program of
length m and width 2 to the s
a branching program basically is a uh is
an acyclic directed graph
where ah where the vertices are divided
into m layers
and each layer
has d vertices uh
has has d vertices in them
each vertex in a layer represents a
memory state of the learning algorithm
so that means that d is equal to 2 to
the memory
and edges are present only from a layer
to the next layer and it represents the
memory state change after seeing the ith
sample
so
so each non-leaf vertex has 2 to the n
prime plus 1 outgoing edges one for each
possible sample of the form a comma b
so let's say this is the ith layer and
there is a there is an edge
labeled a comma b going from this vertex
to this vertex so this means that if my
mem if my learning algorithm was in this
memory state and it read a comma b
as the next sample then it will it will
go to this memory state
a comma b as the ith sample then it will
go to this memory state
so the samples a 1 b 1 sequence of
samples a 1 b 1 a 2 b 2 and a m b m
corresponds to a computation path in
this
branching program so
uh basically you can traverse what
memory states a learning algorithm is uh
is in while uh doing the computation on
uh this sequence of samples by going
through the branching program one by one
layer by layer and
you start at the start vertex
you you look at the first sample go to
this memory state and so on and then you
reach in a memory you reach
at a vertex in the last layer
and and all vertices in the last layer
uh are labeled by a guess for the
unknown function f that is f hat v
ah which is the output of uh
output of the algorithm
if the computation path reached this
memory state
so the success probability of a learning
algorithm can be modeled as the
probability that f at v is equal to f
which was you used to generate these
these samples
any questions for the branching program
model
okay
so this means that for every vertex p
ah we can
it is it is good to analyze the progress
the progress of these belief
distributions that is p f g and v which
corresponds to the distribution of the
function f conditioned on the event that
the computation path reaches v
so this is like
the best knowledge that you can have
about the unknown function f
conditioned on the fact that it reached
this memory state after i steps
and we call a vertex significant
if
um
if uh we call this a vertex significant
if the l2 norm of this belief
distribution
uh is
is large
you do not need to
understand this mathematical formulation
but intuitively this is saying that this
vertex b already has
some amount of information about the
unknown function f
so if ah
okay
then let's say prv is the probability
that the path reaches this vertex v and
we want to show that if v is a
significant vertex then the probability
of reaching this vertex is exponentially
small in k times l
that is if uh and and then if they are
less than a two to the order kl vertices
in the branching program which is the
case if the memory of the learning
algorithm was less than kl
then with high probability we reach a
non-significant vertex a non-significant
vertice is such that the l2 norm is
small that is
there are many possibilities of f
such that we would be we would reach the
same vertex v so we cannot be uh we
should not be able to guess the correct
f with high probability
so this uh proof outline is saying we
prove that either we reach a
non-significa
so we we reach a non-significant with
high probability
and those vertices do not tell us enough
about f
okay so the ma so this is the uh this is
the main um
main hardness this is where
this is the main technical part of the
proof
uh to give you more
technical details on how to prove such a
statement
uh
we analyze a progress function as done
by
the previous paper of run in 2017
so for every layer
li and every significant vertex s we
define a progress function that
basically measures how close this layer
is
to is is from how close is this layer to
the significant vertex s
so it's averaging over the vertices in
the layer in the ith layer and this this
is basically in a product of the belief
distributions and it's measuring how
close
is ah is
is this vertex v in layer i to the
vertex s
in the start zero that is the start
vertex this this pro this
this function has very small value
because in the start you are at
the belief distribution condition on the
start vertex is uniform distribution
over all the function set and it is not
at all close to reaching the signified
vertex s
and then we show that using the
extractor based property that zi should
be growing very slowly
that is uh
that is z0 is basically very close to zm
but
let's say this infinite vertex belongs
to the last layer
then
zm can be small only if the probability
of reaching the significant vertex is
small
and this allows us to prove that if s is
significant then probability of s is
less than equal to is exponentially
small and k times l
okay any questions
okay if
if i lost you in the middle uh
it's this is the time to tune back in
now we will
shift focus and talk about
the implications for
of these results for
proving hardness of refuting csps by low
memory algorithms
this is joint work with probation run
and
so in this work uh we study a related
problem uh a problem related to the
problem of refuting csps under the
streaming model
uh
this problem uh is as follows let's
let's fix a predicate p
which which takes in k bits and outputs
a single bit
and
the goal here is that you have a bounded
memory algorithm and which wants to
distinguish between these two
distributions that is in the first
setting you are getting these constraint
satisfaction problems uh with predicate
p
uh on n variables where the constraints
are randomly generated and in the second
setting uh you are getting uh
constraints
such that there exists a satisfying
assignment for all the constraints
and it is in the streaming model that is
constraints constraints are arriving one
by one in a stream
um
so if if the number of cons when the
number of constraints ah are much larger
than ah n
then we know that uh
csps with balanced predicates p
ah become uh
with high random csps with balanced
predicate p become
uh
unsatisfiable
ah with high probability so this means
that for uh in that regime when
constraints are much greater than the
number of variables uh uh n
in though in that setting a refutation
algorithm that is an algorithm that uh
that that that refutes uh that that is
able to refute that uh
that a constraint satisfaction problem
is unsatisfiable uh is satisfiable uh is
able to distinguish between these two
distributions because
because
in this distribution that if
the refutation algorithm will always
output zero and it would output one ah
in this uh distribution in the first
distribution where the constraints are
randomly generated so this means that in
that in the regime where constraints are
much greater than n refutation is at
least as hard as distinguishing between
random csps and satisfiable ones so
whatever bounce we get for
distinguishing ah distinguishing between
these two distributions in um
in that regime though those bounds also
hold for refutation algorithms
any questions
okay
so more formally uh
so uh so more formally our
problem setup is as follows
you have an x which is an n bit string
and it is chosen uniformly at random
then at each step i
uh
s i is another randomly chosen subset of
uh size k
uh think of s s i is a uh is a
is a subset of
n
and it s i would be used to uh dictate
the ith constraint in uh
okay so right at each step i s is a
randomly chosen subset of size k
s i would be used to generate the ith
constraint
and s i basically dictates that dictates
the k variables that the ith constraint
would be on
so the distinguisher either sees a
stream of uh samples of the form s i
time s i comma p of x s i
or it sees a stream of
samples of the form s i comma b i where
bi is chosen uniformly at random
here x s i is just the projection of x
to coordinates of s i
so this can be thought of as a
constraint because s i is the k
variables that the constraint p is on
and then in this stream of uh in this
stream of constraints which corresponds
to a csp
uh
all the constraints are satisfied by
this
this
unknown chose unknown uh
hidden and bit string x
whereas in the other distribution these
are randomly generated constraints and
uh
and and the and the learner needs to
distinguish between these two streams
okay
so
so we proved that uh so
as mentioned before using the result
that learning from sparse equations is
uh
is hard for low memory algorithms we can
prove that any algorithm that
distinguishes this distinguishes random
kx or
csps on n variables from
kx or c csps with a satisfying
assignment under the streaming model
requires either nk memory or exponential
and k constraints
so
for k much greater than log n it says
that if uh
refuting csps uh which depend on
refutings or csps with sore predicate uh
which depend on much greater than login
variables is hard for algorithms that
are using even super linear memory when
the number of constraints is less than
exponential nk
any questions
sorry i'm a little confused so often
often these
uh memory sample lower bounds have the
flavor of saying that some
some natural algorithm is optimal
uh like if you go a little bit below the
memory used by some natural algorithm
then you'll require exponential uh
samples but maybe i just got lost for a
second but what what's is there such a
is there a natural algorithm to think
about here
yeah so okay so
for the question of learning from sparse
equations the natural algorithm uses n
times k times log n
memory basically each sample
requires k login memory to store for
storage and you can store n samples
okay and once you have n samples then it
becomes easy yeah so it's information
theoretically yeah yeah yeah okay okay
okay great so now you will ask that what
about uh but mostly we care about let's
say three sat uh csps with three set or
or so on so what about referee can we
prove that refutation is hard for
algorithms that use low memory uh
when k is much less than log n
so we do get some hardness results in
that case but for only for algorithms
that use sublinear memory
so
uh here by sublinear memory i mean that
sub linear in the number of variables
that is n
so uh
so when we are talking about algorithms
that use sub linear memory we do not
need to use
the machinery from the previous
the heavy machinery to prove our lower
bounds from the previous
papers
this is because it is very easy to show
that because it is sublinear memory then
even in the satisfiable case
most vertices would not have enough
information about which
which x was used to generate these
constraints
uh and this is like a
very easy argument
so
so for so far uh so from sub linear
memory algorithms we are able to prove
stronger lower bounds on the number of
constraints needed to refute
uh
and
we can generalize these uh
these trade-offs uh even for csps with t
resilient predicates and not just
not just this or predicate
so t resiliency
resiliency of a predicate p
was shown to be necessary for uh
proving hardness of refrigeration of
csps in a different computational model
in previous papers and
it's interesting that this also shows up
in our
in our
lower bounds
so very briefly uh
a predicate p is a t resilient predicate
if p has zero correlation with every
parity function on at most t minus one
bits
so zorr function is k resilient
and ah and then there are many functions
that are
tree resilient and we get lower bounds
that depend on this parameter t
so formally we are able to prove that
any algorithms that distinguish
random csps
with uh random csvs with a t resilient
predicate p on n variables from
satisfiable ones uh when the constraints
are arriving in a streaming fashion uh
require either a memory of size n to the
epsilon
or
n to the t
[Music]
times one minus epsilon constraints
um
and uh and this trade-off holds for many
values of for all values of epsilon uh
uh and this is
uh and this is uh and this this is
basically showing that refutation
because this is uh
whenever this is greater than n
uh much greater than n it is showing
that refutation is hard uh
for uh
uh
for sub for me for algorithms that are
using end to the epsilon bits of memory
uh
okay
yeah that's it thanks
thanks omega we have time for for a
couple questions from here or zoom or
epfl
how about on the epfl side
well one question is what what uh what
what are you in your view what are some
exciting um future directions for this
line of work
so okay so
the the future
okay so one is that we want to go beyond
the extractor based technique to prove
such lower bonds so the extractor uh
uh based property is a very strong
property
it's it's it's it's saying that even if
you choose uh
even if you have
n bits of information uh about uh even
if you have like n by two bits of
information about the function and let's
say
a and by two bits of information about
the sample then also you cannot uh
uh
figure out what what the next uh what
this bit uh what the
matrix entry can be
and this is a very strong property and
we want to
we want to go beyond this and develop
techniques to
prove
memory sample lower bounds for
for even larger class of learning
problems so one problem that to look at
is noisy parity
so in noisy parity
the you can uh so in noisy parity when
each bit is correct only with
probability half plus epsilon uh
for that uh
so okay let me tell you the problem so
under noisy parity again it's the same
thing a parity is hidden and then at
each time step you are getting an
equation but the bit that you get with
that equation is correct only with
probability half plus epsilon
and you can store n n by epsilon square
samples and
this gives you an n square by epsilon
square memory lower bound
ah sorry upper bound uh
to solve this problem whereas uh the the
best lower bound that we know using the
extractor based techniques is that you
require either n square by epsilon
memory or exponential number of samples
and i i believe it's a very exciting
problem to work on to
get a tighter
lower bound for noisy parity
yeah we have another let me run the mic
over
what does known say specifically for
three
yeah for xor
extra it's nothing
and this omega what do you what do you
expect the result to be for for example
3x4
so okay so i believe that
3x we cannot we shouldn't be able
these techniques wouldn't help us in the
setting of 3xor
but
very briefly uh i thought about
using uh so there are these results
where you prove that um
that
solving max cut is just finding a two
approximation from approximation to max
cut uh in a streaming uh setting is uh
hard for
uh algorithms that use or and bits of
space
and uh maybe those kind of techniques
would be helpful in improving
these
proving results for 3xl
and and what would the lower bound be
like what do you expect
the trade-off between memory and
constraints
like what would match an upper bound
i assume so
i i yeah i don't know i i would guess
that it might
like i i cannot on the top of my head
think of a better low memory algorithm
okay
thanks yeah thanks
hey let's thanks mango once more
okay yeah thanks
and we're really doing a good job with
the schedule today i'm so proud of us